quand un athlète canadien gang une
médaille d'or aux jeux olympiques
le canada lui verse une prime de 20
mille dollars mais savez-vous que des
pays qui sont beaucoup plus généreux au
canada chaque mail à hêvié avec une
récompense en argent si l'or vaut 20
mille dollars l'argent rapporte 15 mille
dollars en primes et ses dix mille
dollars pour une médaille de bronze
ce genre de primes existent depuis les
jeux de pékin est depuis 2008 le comité
olympique canadien a versé plus de 13
millions $ aux différents mets
d'ailleurs intervenu sur lequel nos
champions doivent par contre payer de
l'époque
d'autres pays qui sont beaucoup plus
généreux le kazakhstan par exemple offre
313 milles dollars pour une médaille
d'or aux jeux d'hiver
par contre depuis 1994 il ya aucun
kazakh qui est monté sur la plus haute
marche du podium
c'est yapo va jusqu'à offrir près d'un
million de dollars pour une médaille
d'or en sachant cela on souhaite bonne
chance à madame chez bingo qui est la
seule représentante singapourienne a
bien changé en passant madame cohabitent
m linton depuis qu'elle a l'âge de 4 ans
plus sérieusement les etats-unis ont
récemment décidé de bonifier la prime
qu'ils offrent maintenant près de 50000
dollars canadiens non imposables pour
une médaille d'or d'autres pays comme la
suède la norvège ont une approche
complètement différente mais pas de
primes pour les médailles par contre
toutes les sommes sont investies dans le
développement des athlètes
après la gloire olympique d'athlètes lui
aussi tenté de vendre son image
prenons l'exemple de l'américaine
lindsey van est la reine du ski alpin
vont littéralement des millions de
dollars et la valeur des commandes va
dépendre de plusieurs choses
la popularité du sport le charisme de la
khl est mais aussi la taille du marché
qu'il représente au canada même le plus
charismatique des lay dying cross
channel telle fortune et en plus le
succès et les contrats sont souvent très
éphémère comme nous a dit alexandre
bilodeau double médaillé d'or en poste
n'est pas pour l'argent que des athlètes
travaillent pour aller aux jeux
olympiques bref même les 20 mille
dollars que donne une médaille d'or ce
n'est rien comparativement à tous les
sacrifices que l'athlète doit faire pour
atteindre ce genre de sommet là c'est
pour ça que même si ce sont les athlètes
qui nous font vibrer par leur passion et
leur détermination c'est clairement pas
eux qui empoche les milliards de dollars
que rapporte la tenue des olympiques
[Musique]